the Joe Rogan experience like a lot of
hockey players have no [ __ ] teeth but
they that's a badge of honor Franchi
players they don't give they got enough
dick
they'd like [ __ ] this she liked to take
him out and show you in Canada you see
him off like that you think he's a
millionaire and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
Ohio's like that month was hitting that
myth have you ever seen the photograph
for that old school hockey player who
has all these scars all over his face
no I don't know do you know I'm talking
about Jamie it's it was a recreation of
every scar this guy had ever had on his
face over his career I there's a it's a
famous photograph and you could see
these mean it looks like he's just been
in a [ __ ] box cutter fight his whole
face is butchered yeah cuz all they did
was look at this guy's face yeah that's
it and what was it large yeah yeah bro
he's a goalie before they were mask bro
dennah like when i'm kha'zix cause
cosmetic surgery facilities in LA dude
he was a goalie before they used [ __ ]
masks look at him like he was just
straight face they would just take it in
a mug son you mentioned a guy slap
sticking one of those [ __ ] hard-ass
pucks
how fast can they make those things go
now they can make him go well over 100
hundred twenty by 40 oh my god really
I'll check fastest lap shot yeah I think
it's you have you seen the folio of that
dude who does that long drive with the
golf club do you know I'm talking about
this is Jeff deulim there's this really
jack dude who hits his guy he's got this
crazy step through happy Madison or
happy gilmore type stroke to it and he
makes the ball four
you know it's like one of those outdoor
ranges it flies over the back net it's
the most ridiculous thing I've ever seen
in my life oh you probably saw the clip
of somebody hitting it out like at the
top shotgun whose step sideways he steps
to it like happy gilmore ladies about to
kill it it's bonkers
how far that thing flies I want to find
out what they smell Slayer wasn't it he
holds the maybe he looks like a bass
beat he's a big dude he looks like he
looks like a pro baseball player but he
holds the long
distance world record for for a golf
ball drive like drove at the furthest so
he holds the record dude it's the
craziest [ __ ] I've ever seen in my life
and I don't follow hockey like I've been
to one hockey match I was in New York I
think with the Rangers played somebody
but I've been to a couple they're fun
it's wild in person you know it's on TV
there's a lot of things like that
stand-up is a good example there's a lot
of things like that we see it on TVs
like that looks good but if you're there
like oh [ __ ] and watch you escape that's
what it would the interest for me then
you know yeah I'm black you go to hockey
my you like you just want to see a fight
you like this monition you don't even
know who's playing who you like oh [ __ ]
he just [ __ ] him up do so how to fight
now there's some hockey fights where you
watch guys throw like crisp punches like
with technique you know oh Jesus
you think they trained for a hundred
percent oh yeah yeah you can fight it's
the only sport where you can fight like
look you do you practice hitting the
puck yeah okay we'll practice beating
the [ __ ] out of people can I do that -
that's protective part of the game part
of the game is beating the [ __ ] out of
each other that's the well there's no
other sport just let up and think about
that no no other sport we could fight
bare-knuckle in the middle of an ice
skating rink at a drop of a hat well
yeah if they continued and continued to
be friends at the internet [ __ ] and the
referees I'll let you do it they step
back yeah they never like keep talking -
they never like [ __ ] ya'll meseta
mars-like pop up I got it there's some
videos that dudes getting flatline no
it's different than it was back in the
day because back in the day there were
tough guys who knew how to skate and
could maybe fight a little bit and so
they'd grab each other's [ __ ] their
jackets or grab their or their clothes
and they'd be punching each other slam
and move it on now dudes are hitting
guys with hip throws and slamming them
onto the ice and knocking him
unconscious but I seen a dude about hit
a guy with a perfect counter right hand
a dude swung around him he backed up
like this - right there let it pass
right yeah just hit victim oh that guy
could fight that's a that's a guy with
real skills that's a smart [ __ ]
yeah he just stood right in front the
guy who left the guy threw a punch and
then BOOM
countered I could even imagine having
that uh you know you might have to fight
to balance yourself on skates it's just
like
do gather I wonder how you compare that
like the a scatter does this guy this
guy he jacks it God didn't even really
run up to he's called the swing man I'm
saying he's run up to it but he picks
his leg up it's a weird watch's move see
that you got a bunch of videos of him
106 miles an hour for the fastest laps
that's insane that's so fast with that
puck 106 miles an hour that puck hits
you in the face some people can pitch
that faster right I don't want the world
record of pitches whats the world record
pitch well I'll just I'm gonna guess my
guess 111 is that ridiculous 105 yeah
orders Chapman damn that's funny how do
you hit that his mother be connected
with this [ __ ] how many times can they
throw that fast that's it you can do it
a couple times in a row I think he burns
his arm up pretty fast
I would imagine how could you not burn
your arm out think of how much explosion
is involved in this god damn that was a
that was a blink of an eye it's
interesting like the mechanics of when
you watch her a real amazing pitcher
this is crazy body torque going on look
at this whip there's so much in that man
there's like there's so much mechanical
movement and leverage in your legs that
recent coordinate I was like within the
last 10 years there's nine years ago
there's this video of the bird that's
flying by right when the pitch comes at
it and I quoted Islamic explodes that's
crazy was it Randy yes right oh yeah
Randy Johnson the rocket he used to tear
[ __ ] up he was exciting he I don't know
when his doing his era people were
excited because all in the news I watch
this watch this damn he hit the bird
right in mid-flight and the bird
exploded imagine - at the end for that
birdie book how the [ __ ] look at the
world has a plan here's your plan birdie
oh yeah oh ceremony level nothing know
that birds dead as [ __ ]
imagine that I mean that dudes throwing
a hundred miles an hour right or 90s
ultimate sub that told me not to turn
right there Matt oh no just went right
by it I guess one-minute video mechanics
did go back to that the video again the
part where Randy Johnson look at look at
the mechanics of how he throws his body
into that pitch look at this you step
off there's so much good it's like a
little coordinated movement he's really
in any matter yeah what support can
leverage no matter what's 11 who's that
big yeah just think about all that
leverage man plus he can reach almost a
foot closer if not more than that than
any other picture so he's literally
releasing it at a closer distance than
anybody else you know so yeah well last
time that's true it's a good way to look
at it that leverages leverage is
interesting man you know cuz it's such a
it's such a huge factor in some sports
you ever throw a pitch out no way
alright barriers I want to hurt my
shoulder it's just like your ego cuz he
had one shot of 50 cent throwing a pitch
out and he looked so gay doing it was
funny yesterday I think he probably had
that deleted from the internet
[Applause]